[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com slash the
minimalists
um so i
started listening to you guys i saw your
your documentary on netflix a couple
years ago and i probably minimized
around 70 to 80 percent of my
possessions got rid of my storage unit a
couple months ago
um so
my question is is the remaining items
that i do have i find that
there's an
intensification of an attachment to it
um and so i find myself on my days off
i'm like okay i want to i want to finish
these minimization projects and i'm i'm
almost there i'm on my
last rung of digital organization
my question is but that's
even that's a form of attachment so
in this process do you guys find that
you're able to find a sen
a sense of wholeness
without being quote unquote finished
with all of your projects towards
minimization
yeah i think we're we're in an
incredibly dangerous place right now i
think this is one of the sort of
pernicious aspects of the whole
decluttering movement or whatever you
want to call it tidying up etc those
things are really helpful and someone
like marie condo understands the why
behind the the how-to side of things
but quite often it gets propagated in
the media and elsewhere as hey if you
just declutter your closet you just
declutter your house then you're going
to be happy then you're going to be
finished i heard you say it right i'm
almost finished well that presupposes
that there's a finish line and that
minimalism is a destination
but it's not minimalism's merely the
vehicle
right and so it's taking you wherever
you want to go right and and quite often
we mistake the vehicle for for the
finish line and once i've it's like
imagine
like ryan
gets into his not tesla
it's a toyota um
and um he gets in his toyota and he he
wants to go get something to eat but
instead of going to get something he
just gets in the toyota says well i
guess i'm finished right i finally got
there you didn't get anywhere right it's
merely it's going to take you where you
want to go and the question is then
what is my arrival point where do i want
to go and how will minimalism serve me
on that journey because otherwise it
just becomes about getting rid of the
stuff and then you'll you'll never get
though you'll turn into a spartanist
which is the opposite of a hoarder we
did an episode about this recently so
spartanus for those of you who are
uninformed is just an
obsessive-compulsive declutterer
basically
and so it's a person who can't stop
letting go
well that's we want to avoid that as
well both of these people are on the
same spectrum hoarders can't let go of
anything a spartanness can't hold on to
anything a minimalist is on a different
spectrum altogether it's the
intentionality spectrum and you can be a
minimalist like me and ryan or you can
go even farther and you can be a a monk
or or an ascetic right someone who lives
with very few items but does so
intentionally or you could even be a
maximalist there are some great
maximalist designers out there who
use objects in a way that is very
intentional it would be clutter for me
but it serves great purpose for them the
question is how am i going to live my
life
so it gets me where i want to go
if you don't know where you want to go i
can promise you you won't get there
oh
um
i'm trying to say this in the kindness
kind of way you'll you'll
there is no there is no finish line with
that with the decluttering projects now
there might be
a certain
thing that's happening where you're
finally like tidying up everything and
that's incredible and i find that you
know i am constantly i get tidied up and
then you know all the you know the [ __ ]
the junk drawer starts to become two
drunk drawers you're like oh no like i
have to do this tidying up thing again
but you know minimalists they don't
focus on
less less less they focus on
more it's creating more time
it's creating more freedom more
creativity more experiences so the
question is is what are you freeing up
all that time for what are you freeing
up that space for and maybe you don't
have an answer for that that's okay
but that's really
where
where i was drawn to minimalism i didn't
see it as like a as a magical bullet
answer was like oh if i throw all my
stuff away i'm gonna immediately start
experiencing perpetual bliss like anyone
could do that and still be miserable
right
for me it was regaining control of my
finances
it was regaining control of my time
it was making it so i didn't have to
uh
work 60 70 80 hours a week to pay off
you know all that debt that i have
accumulated
so
yeah i would ask yourself what are you
freeing up all of this space for the the
literal and
the metaphorical space what are you
freeing all that up for
it's beautiful
thank you thank you thank you so much
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free